this has been a great great day here so
far we got to talk Power Rangers Star
Wars and now you guys are gonna get to
watch a full conversation with with an
industry icon we have Sean Astin here
and I am so so excited to go through his
entire filmography talk about just his
influence in his hopes for the industry
two movies and TV and everything this
guy is a special one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello so just so you have the heads-up
this is like this magical cube that at
the end of the panel we're going to toss
it out I mean like really throw it at
you if someone has a question there's a
microphone in it is it on so if you guys
have questions and you want that cube
start thinking of them now because we're
gonna save some time at the end of the
panel for those I was thinking the same
thing but I figured this would be a
better audio quality you can throw that
one it's perfect I promise
hi everyone you have so many iconic
movies on your resume that I didn't know
where to start so the only logical place
for me to start is the very very
beginning was there ever a part of your
life where you thought maybe I wanted to
grow up and be something that wasn't an
actor especially being a
second-generation actor I thought you're
gonna say The Goonies as I get I could
go on and on about well know as the very
very beginning but then I would have had
to correct you and say no there was
something before that you know what I
thought I was very passionate about it
my mother the wonderfully beautiful
famous and talented Patty Duke I don't
know if you know who patted you guys she
arranged it so that I could star
opposite her in an ABC after-school
special
remember those kind of an issue of the
week ours was subtly titled please don't
hit me Mom so when you go back to the
beginning I think of I think of that yes
I actually wanted to keep my options
optional all through my young teenage
years maybe a teacher maybe a politician
maybe I don't know something more fun an
archaeologist I didn't realize you could
actually be Indiana Jones but okay
no so-so so I did it wasn't until I was
18 when I kind of got the sensation that
if you wanted to if I really wanted to
make it go of a career as an actor that
just being comfortable in front of the
camera wasn't going to be enough you
have to you have to have a little bit of
craft a little training or at least an
approach to what you're doing so so I
ended up studying for a very brief time
with one of the legendary acting
teachers in American history Stella
Adler and I took her master class and
then a another class or two off to the
side and it was yeah it was just enough
to to give me a sense of what what that
learning space is and what yeah what
people who really have a technique look
like so I could maybe mimic that a
little bit even if I didn't have my own
you know way of doing it and then and
then you know so the answer is yes she
asks a simple question I talked for 45
minutes
it all kind of circles back though
because like you have done that I mean
you're heavily involved in politics
you've also done things that are kind of
like acting programs right you have
essentially taught or at least through
through like you're you're speaking yeah
no I do I mean I do all kinds of
different things all different settings
and environments of yeah you're talking
about speeches or programs guest
lecturing and all that kind of stuff but
so yes I've done a little bit of that
but but the cool thing about acting is
it doesn't matter how old you are when
you start and you never fully retire no
matter what you do because you could
always be pulled out of retirement to do
something else you know if you're if who
you are at the moment that somebody
wants you to do something is right for
that part you you can do it you know is
there any advice your mom gave you at
the very beginning that you've held on
to even to this day
absolutely lots of good stuff one of the
things was hit your mark and say your
line you know they put like a little T
mark on the ground right and you kind of
you're a kid I was kid I was eight years
old you don't know that but
now you know right where to go and you
have to learn not to not to look down at
it because then you kind of takes you
out of the shot you know so you're kind
of there's a tee right there so you sort
of learn how to kind of glance and hit
your mark that's kind of a good one John
Wayne was the best John will be like
well pilgrim I'll tell you what Bill
Grimm she also taught me to be better
off camera than on camera meaning when
you have a scene partner and they're
doing this the scene partners close up
you want to give as much of yourself as
possible that's what it means to be a
professional that advice makes me so
happy I can't even begin to tell you but
mostly what she taught me wasn't
something that she said in words it was
the power of her example and she worked
incredibly hard she was a very
hardworking human being and that work
ethic I think is what enabled me to
develop longevity with my career you
have had a very successful career but I
always think it's important especially
for anybody out there who wants to get
into the industry to hear about an
opportunity for you to overcome failures
so even with so many movies coming your
way at such a young age is there any
time where something didn't work out and
you had to give yourself like a little
pep talk to get out of the rut the ratio
is it's quite severe of things that
you've done that turned out successfully
to things that you failed doing I mean
like 99 to 1 there have been thousands
of auditions that I either messed up or
wasn't didn't prepare in the right way
or thought I was great and didn't get or
got and then lost so there's the the
yeah there's there's any number of most
of the time it's not working most of the
- almost all of the time it's not
working so you have to have something in
your you
body mind and spirit that says to you
that it is inevitable that it will work
and that's only true if it's true and
there's only one way to find out if it's
true and it's to develop that attitude
and not quit you know I'm so curious cuz
you brought up like you could have
gotten a part in one situation and then
lost it are there any examples of that
happening that you could share it's like
a fascinating experience cuz like I
can't even imagine being the person to
say hey I got I'm gonna take it back now
that's my favorite way of firing someone
or breaking up with someone you sort of
go anyone who's still with me take one
step forward uh uh not so fast um one
thing that were my that I'm reminded of
is when my wife and I were in college in
the mid 90s early 90s I started doing
television pilots and I think I did
seven or eight of them and most of them
didn't go well one of them I was I was
cast at the last minute I was the last
last-minute addition to this thing and
if you know anything about television
pilots it's a very intimidating
fast-paced high stakes of ninety-nine
percent failure exercise and you know
you have to sign a contract that's for
like seven years of your life as soon as
you put your name on there you that's it
seven years
you sort of go like well that'll be my
that would be my 20s if I sign the thing
that's my 20s and so but they don't have
to choose you you sign it and other
people are next to you all sign it and
you go in there and you you do your
thing and afterwards you stand outside
and you're waiting for Caesar to be like
you know so I got this one job and it
was so thrilling and I get there and
everybody was so awkward and the
director was a very very successful
television director and he's telling us
what to do and I'm trying to do it and
it's just very clear minutes into the
first day that I am like out of my
league that either I don't understand it
or it's like that whatever the jokes are
that are in the thing
aren't coming across so and at the end
and then what they usually what you do
is you work you do a table read then the
next day you come in and you rehearse a
little bit and then the next day and and
at the end of the day you do a version
of the show you know you like go through
the whole show and they decide like okay
we're gonna make some changes and then
the next day at the end of the day the
network executives come down and that's
where people's jobs are decided and and
any any actor who's worked in sitcom
television now will tell you that you
know no one is safe it's like you know
Simon Cowell sitting there you know
buzzing you off the thing or something
but so they this day because they had
waited so late the network came down and
watched the the Tuesday well it was
terrible and I knew it was terrible and
I was so mad and after it was over I go
and I get my car and I think I had one
of those phones that was like you had to
hold the brick of the phone up like this
and I called my agent and I'm like I'm
so mad why and I was I don't even know
what I was matter if I was mad at the
director mad at the actors are just mad
at the circumstance and he said well
Sean listen they're probably not even
going to shoot it but first they're
gonna try and replace you I was like do
I still get paid yeah you still get your
money I was like whoo let's go to Hawaii
so it is hard to get opportunities
especially with pilots but really in
general across the board but also a
really important thing especially when
you're someone who starts so young is
not just taking every opportunity you
can because it's there but it's carving
out the right path for you so were there
ever any instances where you got like a
big huge part that would have really
excited anyone and you just said to
yourself this is not right for me right
now no I wish you would have been my
manager back then because I do know what
my career could have been but I was not
very discerning I would I would do
anything I was I was just so happy to be
working and and the money you know one
thing that when you're in a convention
setting it's it's not so sexy to talk
about like your fee you're acting fear
what you get paid but it's important for
for me to say particularly to young
actors that are out there or whoever
that like it's a job you're making a
living I now have three kids one just
graduated from Harvard I've got two
other kids upfront yeah
Ali's here well there she is right there
they stand up wait hold on yeah they
come here come here
raise your hand if you recognize Ali
couple oh here we go here we go
over there yes Ali in the last shot of
the last scene of the last film of the
trilogy of Lord of the Rings plays
Eleanor the little girl who comes
running down the road to greet Samwise
and I've been stuck next to you ever
since and made you you've got no choice
Ali just graduated with a degree in in
drama with an emphasis on playwriting
and a secondary in English that
good-looking guy Bobby next to her he's
a football player for Harvard so it's
money and money is important and when I
was when I was getting if I got a job I
was the I think the agents probably had
a more like a sense of taste and
discretion about what they might want me
to do but usually anything that came
down the pike but I got I I didn't get
jobs like in stand by me brilliant movie
would not have been as good if I was in
it
what Wheaton was way better for that
part um a lot of a lot of films that I
would have liked to be in that I did not
you run out for Gordy was it Gordon no
that was Will Wright chambers Chris
Chambers yeah well I can't make the
connection from like Mikey from Goonies
to that character neither could Rob
Reiner
but he could make the connection with
Corey Feldman between Corey and Goonies
and Corey in standby
me that makes a lot of sense but they I
mean the performance that River Phoenix
gives in that movie is a is a
generational performance one of my
favorite movies of all time and I have a
dog named Gordie because of it that's
awesome
but I went to the theater in Westwood
Village where I grew up and I watched
that movie with him in it and I I was
just in awe and I really thought either
I I would not have known how to do that
I auditioned for it so I knew what the
stakes for the character were the loss
of was it his father or the abuse from
his father there's something very deep
emotional scarring that he had and River
Phoenix just brought that to the table
just who he was he had that pain somehow
available and I I just didn't that
wasn't in me so it's a good thing I
didn't get that part but I I did learn
and this is another little piece of
guidance for young performers for any
performer actually for every human being
cam 48 I've got so I'm gonna drop some
knowledge right now some powerful life
wisdom you ready when you are passionate
about other people's work extraordinary
things happen take that and put it in
your back pocket and walk around with it
every single day I'm going to borrow
that line and tell anybody that I can so
you said that you jumped at any
opportunity you could the best of my I
mean I guess I turned down certain
things I just can't remember I remember
mostly the ones I failed at but with
everything you did back in the day is
there anything that at the time when it
came out you're like oh I wish I didn't
do that and then it grew on you because
one thing that I'm like a little
obsessed with thinking about right now
is that you can love a film for one
reason at one age or not like a film for
one reason at that age but then when you
grow and you gain new life experience
all of a sudden you view it there are
different lens and it changes so funny I
think related to that is the idea that
when your kids come along you're
desperate to show them the thing that
meant something to you when you were
their age and so I Wow I mean I I really
was not happy during Encino man
I had just done where the day takes you
which was this very serious it's a
wonderful wonderful film with an
extraordinary cast you know this movie
yes that of course you do what don't you
know I I mean this is what we were just
talking about this before you walked on
a stage to like oh I don't do anything
like for free time that does not involve
moot looks like my job involves movies
and then my passion is movie so all day
every day well you're gonna have to go
to movies with my wife and me because we
come out of a movie and Christine is
like just letting the experience of
having watched the movie like wash over
her and I'm like but what about this and
what about that and what about the other
thing and she's like just she just
enjoyed them like you just enjoyed the
movie but then I could be like yes honey
hold on what did you and then you and I
can deconstruct it at Collider that is
what we do every single day and I
couldn't be happier to do it what's the
last movie you guys saw together like in
the theater it wasn't that one you got
an answer for me last movie mom and I
saw together she's been seeing a lot
like she's seen the Avengers did like
the last one she saw a good choice yeah
I am what is the last note I don't I
can't remember you know we've been
watching a lot of television so there is
absolutely nothing wrong with that given
what the Gilmore Girls you guys were
watching Gilmore Girls oh my god I'm
like watching it on the plane until the
plane gets out of the wi-fi's mode and
like going to sleep last night we had
this great dinner at the hotel and then
these two are gonna go walking through
Vegas and I'm like watching season 6
episode 4 of Gilmore Girls it's so I
would have been such a better parent I'm
so sorry that I didn't watch it sooner I
would have been way better I've got
three Lorelei's I've got three Rory's I
don't know if you guys know but so and
we watch that we basically Christine and
are the two younger ones and I will have
several series going
you know I tried been traveling a lot so
they'll be like hey meet me at friends
episode you know season 4 episode 9
that's what we're gonna go sleep
watching tonight so I'll go to sleep
watching that and then if we talk on the
phone the next day I was like oh my god
kids we'll need Rachel did that you know
so I just can't remember what feature
phone Christine and I watched together
like I love the fact that you guys share
all of your like entertainment love's
together that's so important well I mean
I get kind of sick of romantic comedies
like so I mean I love them and they're
fine we just watch oh I got it fools
fools fools fools gold fools rush in
fools
the one with Matthew McConaughey and
those gold right football yeah we just
watched fool's gold together okay yeah
is that what I thought you were gonna go
for it's exhausting it's great it's
Goonies with like sex appeal that's one
way to describe it one question I've
been asking a lot lately because I'm
trying to force myself to rewatch or
watch for the first time the person's
answer every single time is what is the
movie that you quote the most oh I heard
an answer over there would you say hitch
hitch which what line like what's one
line of the dancing thing q-tip q-tip
yeah Fletch is one that I quote a lot
you guys remember Chevy Chase oh my god
I mean we quote I quote so many
different movie Jaws I don't know I
can't even think it's it's
situation-specific
you know there's always some moment that
you can add yeah I don't know I think
one of my favorite lines of yours is in
the Goonies and it's it's not like the
tip of a Goonies never say die even
though I love that kind of stuff too but
it's when you get on the ship and Andy
goes like do you think there's treasure
here and he says this whole thing is a
treasure I don't know that just always
kinda is a treasure
yeah yeah I am terrible at quoting my
own movies absolutely terrible the Rudy
speech we're gonna go inside outside
inside and outside we're gonna get on
the run boys and once we get on the road
we're gonna keep around the right where
to go go go go we're not going to stop
then we get across that go like there's
like it actually but I didn't even do it
go go go go go so I I did a signing a
private signing in on the East Coast
recently and the guy wanted me he had
these big pictures of Rudy from that
scene in the locker room and he wanted
me to write the whole speech and it's
like way longer than what I just read I
mean I was at the end of it I was like
oh my god I can't write anymore
but let me I know I'm not that good like
I know in the two towers I think I
understand now mr. Frodo it's like in
the great tales the ones that really
matter folk in those stories have lots
of chances to turn it back only they
didn't they kept going and then he
talked about the Sun the Sun will shine
out the clearer something like that yeah
even this darkness must pass and the Sun
will shine out to play something like
that and then the bit about there's some
good left in this world mr. Frodo and
it's worth fighting for but I'm not
great I don't quote my movies very much
yeah it's a lot to remember especially
when you keep adding more and more
projects today we were just watching the
the bloopers for Miller's meat is it
meat the Millers we're the Maryland
we're we're the Millers we're the
Millers and the kid who works in the
kick carnival with with rag rats you get
no rat grass he's like not one not one
regret not one letter sound Sam he's
like well I'm awake and I have the power
of thought so yes I do see what you're
saying
so Sam you've given me like a laundry
list of things to watch now and I'm
totally cool with it I also wanted to
ask you about your interest in writing
and directing because I remember you
were going for like maybe TV pilots or
something before is that still kind of
like an itch you have to scratch yes
I've been away from it from a lot for a
long time I tried very hard to hurt my
wife and I were going to produce and I
was going to direct the adaptation of
Lois Lowry's first Newbery award-winning
book Number the Stars and we tried we
spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
and
ten long years fighting to get that
movie made and failed so which is a
bummer it was a total bummer that we
didn't get that done but at the moment
now that I've just done some comedies on
television did you guys see no good Nick
do you know what no good Nick is if you
go to Netflix now
okay so Bob spoilers stranger thing
spoilers so Bob is eaten by demo dogs in
season 2 episode 8 or 9 8 8 you know the
episode number that's your Greek I I'm a
freak because I'm a Jurassic Park Creek
it's my favorite movie of all time and
the Jurassic Park influence is all over
that episode we were walking through
Disneyland two days ago we went and saw
the Star Wars the galaxy's edge so
jealous I know it's amazing
someone brought me back a t-shirt from
galaxy's edge and I'm like well that's
nice but I'd like to have picked it up
myself
is it what's the name of the land the no
the the plan I - bah - yeah but I didn't
want to see it wrong if I got it wrong
it could sound bad you the black spy
outpost I'm right right so you you're
welcome to visit the rebels have taken
up a stronghold there but the the Empire
the first order is searching them out
but you can get all kinds of creatures
and but anyhow so we were walking
through the park and we were trying to
come up with our favorite movie themes
and it was like for a couple hours we
were we were singing and forgetting and
remembering themes that you just said
Jurassic Park
right yeah it's a fun game to play I
highly recommend it we get stuck on Star
Wars or Star Wars on Star Trek
yeah can you do it anybody do it that's
pretty good so but was I gonna say
something before that about lost the
thread I've kind of completely lose it
how we got here Bob Newby sorry
okay just uh stranger things just
testing so Bob is this wonderful sort of
wannabe stepfather to the kids who
happens to give some of the worst advice
ever given in the history of film to
entertainment tells them to stand up to
the monster well intentioned but bob is
essentially reincarnated on another show
a half-hour sitcom called no good Nick
and I'm I'm Edie Edie is the is the dad
on the kid show you know hey guys come
on everybody you know like super happy
dad guy so there's that if you're really
really upset about Bob migrate over to
no good Nick actually bringing up
stranger things I'm curious your
experience working on that is there
anything that like really surprised you
that you took with you whether it was
you know a surprising member of that
cast that really exceeded your
expectations or the way that the
directors work anything like that well
will the boy in the who's know a snap
yeah nope but the ket but his when we're
in the hospital setting and he's in the
bed and he's been possessed his
performance in that bed was absolutely
mind-blowing I mean and he we walked in
the first day and he lays down and kids
now who are working in movies are
professionals they show up ready to work
they know their lines they they are they
they're all business not all business
they're still kids but I mean there's
just no from my vantage point
you know obviously they don't have as
much life experience but but they are
professionals on the set like anybody
else and you don't really need to make
many accommodations for them they're
just doing their character and you're
doing your character and he comes in and
we start to rehearse and he starts
thrashing and screaming and crying and
doing this now you know
basically the only people in the room
were the director the cinematographer
maybe one of the writers but I don't
even think one of the writers and then
Winona and me and and him and he's
screaming everything else and and that
they said okay you know let's let's talk
about this let's talk about that and I
walked over to him and I'm like save it
dude
and he looked at me like what do you
mean I was like listen it's cool to have
like one speed which is 100% all out
flat out all the time I was like but
what you're gonna need to do is learn
when to really because you won't be able
to sustain that no one could be able to
sustain that level of intensity during
all the different angles and setups and
takes and you know that scene probably
took five hours and you can't lay on a
bed screaming and yelling for five hours
my god he you know he did three hours
and 45 minutes at least I mean that he
was so in terms of a surprise that was I
don't know if I was surprised but I was
in all of that he is something else
before we toss it to the audience I like
literally actually I have one more
question for you because I was like just
looking up some random facts online so
for all I know this isn't true but I
read it that you had interest in
directing a Fantastic Four movie and
given the fact that we are at a comic
convention right now I'm curious what
your take on it was so it sort of told
this whole story last night it's a long
story it took maybe an hour of our
dinner I really thought that would be a
cool thing to do coming off of Lord of
the Rings and the the coolest thing may
not be what's cool well no actually you
guys would appreciate this the campaign
to get the job is what was amazing there
had been many screenplays over years
that the studio had developed include
Christopher Columbus had developed a
screenplay Chris Columbus had developed
a screenplay so I went and tracked down
and it's not as easy as it sounds where
those screenplays were so I could read
them so I could see what the evolution
of the the story that you know that the
studio was buying and it's a little bit
shocking like I actually think most of
the people in the convention could do a
better job of developing most of these
franchises than the studio executives
themselves because they and that they
probably think that too which is why
they're scouring you remember the last
starfighter
yes with Lance gasps yeah so everybody
in here it's like this is these panels
are your video game test they are
watching they will come down out of the
sky and pluck young writers up to take
you in the Hollywood it doesn't hurt so
but they they'll base they'll come up
with a writer will come up with a take
or the executive will have a take and
they'll find a writer who really
understands the approach and then
they'll hire them and they send them out
for a period of time and then they get
the the script back and sometimes it
bears no resemblance to what was agreed
upon and it's better or it bears a lot
of resemblance to what was agreed upon
and it's not very good and then they
start the process of you know well we're
gonna give you some notes and then you
will you know we'll give you these notes
and then you go back and work on it for
another month and then you give it and
it goes back and forth like that and
sometimes it's just like riding one of
those like a broken toy horse outside of
a shopping cart it's like oh this isn't
working but um but on that one I went
and I found all of those screenplays and
I really tried I remember calling Chris
Columbus who is just on the whatever
Harry Potter v Harry Potter or something
like that and because he wrote The
Goonies he took my call and I said
listen I really want to direct this not
really knowing that he was slated to
direct it for a period of time and he
shepherded that that I don't know if he
actually wrote the draft that I wanted
to look at I don't think he
but it was in his control 1493 control
and and and he said well you know I was
they we had talked a lot about me doing
it and I was like wow are you are you
gonna do it and he said I don't think so
because the version I want to make would
cost two hundred million dollars and I'm
like yeah mines really about 30 million
so give me the script so but he he was
kind enough to let me I drove over to
the studio I got his script I read it
when I went in to meet with the the head
of I called my lawn my lawyer and the
partner the head partner in the firm was
one of the most important powerful
lawyers in Hollywood and Jake bloom and
you could never even if you're a client
at the law firm nobody talks to Jake he
represented Schwarzenegger when
Schwarzenegger was governor you know and
all through the terminators and stuff
and I'm like Dave I want to meet I want
Jake to call Tom Rothman the head of
20th Century Fox and tell him that Sean
Astin wants to direct Fantastic Four and
he was like you're out of your flippin
mind he goes if you directed a feature
like no not yet
it was like well I can't I was like I
want you to call him and I want you to
tell him and and I made it he could tell
how serious I was and so sure enough
Jake bloom called Tom Rothman and said
this kid Sean Astin wants to direct
Fantastic Four he's like kids out of his
flippin mind so he took a meeting - he
took we took a meeting oh and the other
thing I had done was I started flying
myself all over the world to the
different special-effects houses I went
up to Lucasfilm I went to Warner
Brothers had a big thing in in London I
went to see obviously new New Zealand
Lord of the Rings I knew who their shot
pretty good so but I really wanted to
make sure that I was as up-to-the-minute
as I could possibly be on what was going
into making this film so and I had and
the other thing was I'd gotten a call
back from Kevin Fahey you know who that
is
is a head of Marvel so he called he
wasn't the head of it then he was had a
physical production then and he called
me because I was just starting in Lord
of the Ring so like there was a moment
where you could just
call people and and I said listen is
there any way in the world I would be
you know that you'd consider me to
direct Fantastic Four and he was like
well I don't know and blah blah blah I
said or so are you saying there's zero
chance zero no chance 100% not gonna do
it he says well I'm not gonna say 0% I'm
like hole so I was actually a Bauman's
rare book dealership in on Madison
Avenue and I grabbed a metamorphosis the
book metamorphosis by Ali metamorphosis
Kafka thank you
Kafka $5,000 so I didn't buy it I put it
on hold jumped in a cab went to Midtown
comics
I called Midtown comics and I'm like
every single I didn't know anything
about it I wouldn't have known anything
from Fantastic Four if you would have
liked if the characters would have
walked in front of me I would have no
idea who they were
but I just knew that it was America I've
been in New Zealand for two years and
this was America it was an American
concept of American heroes and and the
relationship between them and so I so I
said to the guy in Midtown comics listen
I'm coming in I want to buy every single
thing in your comic book store that has
anything to do with Fantastic Four he
was like really I've started thinking
like there's gonna be some first edition
something that's a million dollars don't
be like I don't have a million dollars
but but I went in there and I've got all
this stuff and I'm pouring through it
and I remember I was trying to meet with
Christina Aguilera I thought she'd be
great as Sue Storm I was doing I was I
was it was an amazing time it was like
it was an insane time but I so I go in
to meet Tom Rothman and he looks at me
and he's like what are you doing here I
said I want to direct this movie he goes
all right well this meeting is premature
we've ordered another script it's due in
three weeks from now and he said and all
and I'll let you read it I said if you I
said if I have your commitment to I said
do I have your commitment that if that I
get to read that and have a meeting with
you before you set the director
please can I have that commitment he
said I give you that commitment because
Jake bloom had called him and those are
powerful guys so I was like so I get
this call you can come in tomorrow at
5:00 p.m. go to Rupert Murdoch's office
and you can sit at his desk and read the
new draft so I showed up at 4:00 waiting
and I get in there and I read it and and
this is kind of instructive for anybody
who wants to be a writer or be a
filmmaker or work in studios at all or
anybody's interested in it when I met
with the younger executive before I met
with hutch Parker who was the president
of the studio and so forth he was I was
telling him that my not my my short film
was nominated for an Academy Award and I
and I did this and I did that and I did
the other thing and he was like nobody
cares he goes all they care about is do
you know what we should do with this
character or do you know what should
happen at this point in the story like
why isn't the story working better here
if you can help us make the movie better
on its own terms that's what we really
need so and that was like so liberating
so then I'm sitting at Rupert Murdoch's
desk and I'm reading the script and like
I went into the script my whole like my
creative mind went into the script and I
and I like I got it I got what they were
going for and I got what was wrong with
it really clearly I don't I can remember
it now but so the next morning I go in
to have my meeting with him and Tom
Rothman says uh he says well okay I said
well I said you have he the way he's the
way he did the chitchat I don't know
whatever was but I said well do you have
a question we hadn't even started
talking yet he goes yeah how about the
big one why you I said before they'll
put some 24-year old kid in a hundred
million dollar fighter plane they put
him in the best trainers simulators ever
designed I said from the time I was 12
years old I've been in the best
simulators you could possibly have for
this kind of thing and he goes Oh
okay right so then we started talking
and I said well this is what I think
here and this is what I think there and
then he got up and he started pacing and
he was listening to me and he was like
but what about this and we just had like
a real creative conversation about what
was going on with a with a story and
where they had a written and they he was
really he was like he was impressed he
not just impressed like what you're an
impressive human being but like the
ideas that I was presenting him were
impressed in his mind he wanted he liked
them and then and then I went to this to
a to a boxing match with Chiklis with
Michael Chiklis
and we went out afterwards like I don't
even know how this happened and I'm like
you got a play thing he's like well I
don't know I'm like you can't I was like
that part came down from God for you you
have to play this part there is no one
else on planet earth who can play I was
like do you know who's waiting to see
this this be done do you know the
audience that's that wants you to do
this right now
and I think I talked him into it I don't
know if you would remember this
conversation at all but I'm pretty sure
I've talked about I tried to talk
Cameron Diaz into playing Sue Storm but
she was like wait how long do I have to
be in the makeup and I was like well you
know maybe a WoW is it yeah no I don't
want to do that so I got this call my
mom and I were in DC we had just been
lobbying on Capitol Hill for more
funding for National Endowment of the
Arts or something and my phone rings and
I just knew I just knew and I kind of
looked down I open it hi this is
whatever we have Tom Rothman for you and
I I go OK he said Sean it's Tom I say
hey Tom because I hope you can hear the
good in what I'm about to say and I was
like he goes when Jake Blum called me
and told me that you had never directed
a feature and you wanted director
fantastic for I told him you were out of
your mind
he said I I never I didn't know you
hadn't heard of you you weren't on my
radar at all he said but I want to tell
you something you forced me to take you
seriously as a filmmaker he said so you
may not have been on my radar before but
you'll be on my radar now and and and
you know I said well I'll be first in
line to watch the movie so that's that
story we're in Vegas I do like to bet I
am going to bet there is going to be
another Fantastic Four opportunity in
the future so like maybe you shouldn't
call Feige back I don't know but we only
have a couple minutes left so how about
give a good old Rudy throw ants out into
the audience who has a question okay
it's up to you
to the kid in the jurassic park shirt
good call
no no no you're just right my question
is is what is your favorite character
from Lord of the Rings not Gollum I
really like Treebeard I really like
Treebeard when I read the books
Rosie cut wait Eleanor my favorite do
you want to throw that cube to the next
person with a question look for someone
with their hands up and you could pick
whoever you want okay - did you tell
people more about your documentary
remember the Sultana and how much fun
was it to do icebreaker so remember this
Altana the Sultana was a riverboat like
them like one of those paddleboats in
the 19th mid 19th century on the
Mississippi and right after the well
during the Civil War they were
commandeered and used to kind of ferry
soldiers around and that after the war
was over actually just a few days before
Lincoln was assassinated they had
marched the the the Union prisoners of
war who were in to internment camps
the Andersonville and Cahaba prisoner of
war camps and they marched him this many
many miles to a train and the Train took
him all the way to Memphis and they
boarded this-this-this ferry this uh
this paddle boat
steamboat called this Altana well it was
only supposed to have 300 people on it
and they loaded like 1,200 people on it
and when it was going up in the middle
of the night up the Mississippi the
boiler blew and it sank and it killed
like 1,100 people or
like 800 people something like that it
was a huge huge biggest maritime tragedy
in in US history I think so
so we did a documentary about that I
guess do I narrate it I guess I narrated
and maybe I play one of the voices of
the characters it was available it's
just it's now not available as of
yesterday but I've got a little hint
that something exciting is going to
happen with it so remember this alt Anna
if you like Civil War documentaries you
can have that and then was it called
icebreaker frettin honestly when I look
back at ice I wrote a book and I start
the book out talking about what a piece
of sh this movie is not in a
mean-spirited way it was just that it
was probably a hundred thousand dollar
budget my fee was probably fifty
thousand so it was like fifty thousand
to make the movie and it was it was die
hard on a ski slope and the fact is I
was at about 16 percent body fat I was
in great physical shape that's the best
thing about that movie but actually
Bruce Campbell is in it Stacy Keach is
in it we and and the truth is when I
look back at it now it's a lot better
than I thought it was and i I've learned
not to be so hard on these kinds of
things so the the the filmmakers
themselves are friends and that's that
movie we're about to hit the timer but
how about we get one more question in
it's up to you
all right first person I'll say thanks
for coming to Vegas it's great so happy
to have you here everything that you
have done from Encino man I mean
obviously parted the Rings to everything
so we just actually wanted to know how
it was to be in the last season of the
Big Bang Theory
what a great question and on so first of
all Las Vegas has a very special place
in my heart my biological father Mike
tell owns a Jewish newspaper here in
town and has for most of his life called
the Israelite and he I'm gonna see him
soon tonight so coming to Vegas is
always about my my biological paternity
which is pretty great my godfather Desi
Arnaz jr. lives not too far away in
Boulder City Nevada so I may or may not
get to see both of them on Father's Day
so it's great to be in Vegas and I've
spent a lot of time in this city and in
this region and I love it and I love the
dry heat The Big Bang Theory so my
mother write when Big Bang Theory came
out loved it so we both loved it
instantly and she she really wanted to
play meemaw
Sheldon's meemaw so she recorded herself
singing soft kitty soft kitty warm kitty
little ball of fur something kitty purr
purr purr right so I told Jim Parsons
this when I was working with him he's
like no he's like yeah she did that and
he was like so my late mother got a
moment of recognition for what she did
this convention and any one of the 1200
what I call regional Comic Cons Oh a
huge debt of gratitude to the Big Bang
Theory for popularizing the concept of
being comfortable that you can be both
brilliant
and nerdy or maybe those two things are
linked so you know from the time in the
first episodes of the show them talking
about Lord of the Rings and talking
about Sam what dressing up like Sam wise
are having Gollum or having the ring or
they're different you know just we were
a light motif through the whole 12
seasons so to get a call at the end to
come in and and do three episodes
honestly honestly really just a dream
come true and I like a literal fantasy
an actual I'd spent time fantasizing
about it I you know and and they there's
a scene where we're at a hotel and
Sheldon wants me and Cowpen to have a
news conference to announce to the
world's press that were frauds so he's
just gonna come to us and tell us that
I'd like you to announce that you're
frauds so he knocks on the door
dr. Pemberton dr. Pemberton dr.
Pemberton oh my god I was getting the
pen III knock almost passed out I was
like so excited and in a weird way I saw
an episode a couple of days ago and in a
weird way like I know I'm a part of it
but it's like it's it's it's separate
somehow I don't know how to describe the
feeling but I still feel like I'm
watching that show that I loved so much
in that world the fact that I was in it
for a little bit is like a side note you
know what I mean so I love you guys
anyway thank you so much for the
hospitality have one last question is it
it's from this right there whoa what's
that's really strong
sorry if being a child actor in the 80s
I know it was very tempting to go down a
dark path like a lot of fellow actors
did what advice could you give the young
folks nowadays to make sure that they
stay on a good path to stay away from
some temptations drugs alcohol and
actually become who they want to be
either as young actors teachers lawyers
doctors what kind of Vice could you give
the younger generation
and your movies are awesome thank you
very much a lot of time the people who
are asking me guidance like this are
clearly ambitious and maybe struggling
but know what they want they want it so
bad they can taste it and the advice I
always give to those people is work hard
no matter what's happening just keep
working
work hard be more determined work harder
because ultimately that's what this
industry but really every industry
responds to and rewards your question is
infinitely more challenging and what
would you say to somebody who maybe
doesn't necessarily know yet what they
want or and and what I would say to them
is to always remember that they're not
alone that no matter what's happening in
their life there are people who love
them and care about them and want them
to succeed even if they don't know them
they're there because a lot of times
what sends people down a dark path is a
sense of solitude loneliness it's a
result of some kind of abuse greater or
lesser abuse and I would also say that
you know if people are gonna experiment
with any of the things that are out
there that can hurt you just I wouldn't
talk down to them I would just say
listen before you do whatever it before
you make whatever choice you're gonna
make just think for a minute about the
consequences think about it because a
lot of times when people do the wrong
thing it's out of instinct it's mindless
the hard thing in this life is that
sometimes happiness fulfillment joy all
of these things they're not
they're not ready they're not you know
you can't just go to McDonald's and buy
joy so the concept of like hey you have
to have a little trust or a little faith
that if you do the right things even if
it doesn't seem successful in the moment
the universe responds to right behavior
so yeah there you go
I don't think there's a better way to
end this panel thank you so much for
your time today guys give it up for show
everyone right now thank you guys